whatever happened to madame hooch ron
weasley's brother charlie here's a look
at some of the many harry potter story
lines that just completely disappeared
from the films
madam hooch appears in harry potter and
the sorcerer's stone in a small but
significant moment for the boy who lived
played by zoe wanamaker hogwarts
resident quidditch coach teaches flying
lessons to the first year students
professor mcgonagall observes harry's
natural prowess in the air and gives him
a position as seeker for gryffindor's
quidditch team madam hooch can be seen
refereeing harry's first match against
slytherin where he almost swallows the
golden snitch and then that's the last
we ever see of her even though the
character continues throughout the books
why well actor zoe wanamaker only signed
on for one film which is likely why
madame hooch disappears from the story
after sorcerer's stone
another character to only feature in one
film in the harry potter series is
gilderoy lockhart harry's second defense
against the dark arts professor is
arguably his most inept appearing in
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
lockhart is a charismatic charming
celebrity renowned for successfully
banishing various dark creatures but
he's all style and no substance his
lessons at hogwarts expose him as a
fraud and he admits at the end of the
film that he's taken credit for other
people's work throughout his career
chamber of secrets culminates with a
memory charm backfiring on lockhart
thanks to ron's broken wand lockhart
gets a taste of his own medicine losing
all memory of who he is and then you
guessed it he disappears for the rest of
the movie series hello
who are you
ron weasley really
and uh
who who am i in the books harry ron and
hermione run into an amnesiac lockhart
in saint mungo's hospital for magical
maladies and injuries during harry
potter and the order of the phoenix but
actor kenneth branagh likely wasn't
available to film this cameo for the
movies
sorcerer's stone and chamber of secrets
includes several scenes showing harry's
school lessons from prisoner of azkaban
onwards however harry's classes take
more of a backseat in favor of the
growing drama at hogwarts and beyond the
boy wizards lessons tend to appear only
when something significant happens
harry's flight on buckbeak in prisoner
of azkaban moody explaining the
unforgivable curses in goblet of fire
etc the books have more space to explore
harry's journey but in the films harry
uses several spells seemingly out of the
blue with no prior classroom practice
harry potter and the goblet of fire is a
turning point in the story for
everyone's favorite teenage trio lord
voldemort makes his comeback at last
emerging from a cauldron with no nose
and a thirst for blood while harry ron
and hermione come of age as the series
takes a more dramatic adult tone but
it's not all bad for the golden trio
especially hermione who has a whirlwind
romance with quidditch sensation and
durmstrang student victor crum which
ends with crum asking hermione to write
him after he leaves in the books this
happens but in the movies crumb is
almost entirely absent for the rest of
the series
like hermione harry has a love interest
in goblet of fire cho chang who
initially rebuffs harry for cedric
diggory after cedric dies however harry
grows close to joe during order of the
phoenix harry shares his first kiss with
joe before their budding relationship
quickly goes awry when she spills the
beans to delores umbridge about harry's
secret group dumbledore's army post
order of the phoenix cho graduates from
hogwarts and harry pursues a
relationship with ginny weasley the two
are briefly reunited in deathly hallows
during the prelude to the battle of
hogwarts the film follows a similar path
to the books here reducing joe to a
cameo character after her abrupt breakup
with harry
the harry potter films were mostly
faithful adaptations of the book series
though many characters had to be cut
during the jump from the page to the big
screen multiple members of hogwarts
faculty never or barely appeared in the
films professor bins professor grubbly
plank plus most of the stuff with the
centaurf to name a few one teacher who
did have a cameo appearance before
disappearing from the film series is
professor sinistra sinistra teaches
astronomy lessons throughout harry's
time at hogwarts in the film she is
played by an unidentified actress in an
uncredited role which was later
retconned as professor sinistra when the
actress's likeness was used in the lego
harry potter video games omitting
professor sinistra from the other harry
potter movies was a missed opportunity
for the series in regards to
representation the astronomy teacher's
physical appearance isn't given in the
books though the character was portrayed
by a black woman during sorcerer's stone
in hindsight the films could have
further developed sinistra as a
prominent poc character
ah colin cravey equal parts endearing
and annoying the starstruck student
appears in harry potter and the chamber
of secrets as the boy who lived number
one fan colin is one of the students to
fall victim to becoming petrified by the
basilisk thankfully harry saves the day
by venturing into the chamber of secrets
to rescue ginny weasley and kill the
giant snake chamber of secrets is the
only installment in the harry potter
series to star colin creevy in later
films he is replaced by an original
character called nigel wolpert nigel can
be seen as an amalgam of collins
character as well as his brother dennis
who appears in the books nigel has a
happier ending in harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 2 than his on-page
counterpart in the books colin is killed
by death eaters during the battle of
hogwarts it seems that colin's death was
instead given to lavender brown who in
the films is killed by fenrir greyback
despite surviving the battle in the
books
prisoner of azkaban features some big
changes for harry ron and hermione as
they face their third year at hogwarts
new lessons are introduced such as
professor trelawny's study of divination
and care of magical creatures classes
led by hagrid both classes prove
difficult in different ways harry rides
a hippogriff in his first lesson with
hagrid while trelawny frequently
predicts harry's imminent death after
seeing the grim during a divination
class buckbeak the hippogriff harry
flies on plays a small but significant
role in the third installment draco
malfoy purposely provokes the beast into
attacking him and buckbeak is sentenced
to death thanks to draco's father lucius
thanks to the time turner harry and
hermione managed to rescue buckbeak
before his extermination perry saves
sirius black from the dementors before
his godfather departs with the
hippogriff both of them fugitives from
the ministry of magic in the films
buckbeak's story ends there but in the
books there's a whole storyline with
buckbeak that ends with a moving reunion
with hagrid too bad we never saw it the
final installment in the harry potter
book gives fans their first look at
albus dumbledore's childhood and
subsequent previously unknown history
evil journalist rita skeeter swoops in
shortly after dumbledore's death to drag
the headmaster's name through the dirt
in her revealing biography the life and
lies of albus dumbledore when harry
reads an excerpt in the daily prophet it
triggers a crisis of faith as he is
forced to confront the possibility that
he never knew his mentor's true nature
after all skeeter's biography casts a
shadow on dumbledore's legacy but it
isn't necessarily untrue we learned in
the book that dumbledore was involved
with the dark wizard grindelwald as
harry learns from dumbledore's brother
aberforth aberforth explains that their
sister ariana was attacked by three
muggle boys in her youth causing her
magic to spiral out of control her
father percival went after the muggles
in retribution earning him a life
sentence in azkaban and a sour
reputation for his family ariana was
later left in albus's care after their
mother's death but she was killed
accidentally during a confrontation
between albus and grindelwald however
almost none of this is explained in the
films instead there's just a brief scene
that hints at these events events that
harry explicitly isn't interested in at
all in the film
i'm not interested in what happened
between you and your brother ron's older
brother charlie has the biggest blink
and you'll miss it cameo appearance in
the film series popping up briefly in a
photograph of the weasley family on
their trip to egypt in prisoner of
azkaban besides that charlie is an
absent member of the weasley clan never
appearing properly on screen though ron
mentions charlie in harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone while explaining that
his brother works with dragons in
romania
that's a norwegian ridgeback
my brother charlie works with these in
romania charlie shows up a few times in
the books though the wayward weasley
takes hagrid's baby dragon norbert off
their hands in sorcerer's stone before
returning to hogwarts in goblet of fire
as a handler for the dragons used in the
tri-wizard tournament's first task like
the rest of his family charlie is
present at the final battle against
voldemort in harry potter and the
deathly hallows his exclusion from the
later movies suggests that his character
could have been retconned out of
existence to allow the film to focus on
portraying other weasley siblings like
ginny bill and fred and george
in goblet of fire future doctor who star
david tennant became one of the long
list of acclaimed british actors to
feature in the harry potter series
playing the villainous barty crouch jr
tennant's role in the film was altered
from the source material in the books
when professor moody is revealed to
actually be barty crouch's son disguised
via the power of paulie juice potion
barty crouch jr regales harry with an
in-depth explanation of how he was
broken out of azkaban by his parents
only to reunite with voldemort and help
him enact his plan to capture harry
vardy's tale concludes with him
receiving the dementors kiss for his
crimes the revelation that mad eye moody
is really barty crouch jr is glossed
over pretty quickly in the film though
crouch never explains his motivations or
receives the dementor's kiss dumbledore
remarks that the dementors will find
azkaban's missing prisoner and crouch
promises that he will be welcomed back
like a hero did crouch return to azkaban
after that or did the dementors perform
their soul stealing kiss off screen it
isn't clear crouch's story line like
other characters in the films this
appears without closure or explanation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]